this week on couch tomatoes we're going
back in time with American Horror Story
1984 and giving you our fresh picks on
what to watch what's up guys I'm not
surprised and welcome to the new show
where we tell you what to watch and why
it's called couch tomatoes brought to
you by four shut up heaps of my
favorites so today we're talking all
things American Horror Story 1984 which
is the most anticipated fall show for
run tomato fans and who better than to
talk teenage angst and murder with and
Ryan Bergara and shame a day from
BuzzFeed's unsolved you guys are
hilarious they love your show thank you
so much thanks for having us welcome so
much and my personal scream queen Perry
never I'm so happy to be here with you
who's watched every season of American
Horror Story you guys so I feel like I'm
with the Avengers of horror that's it
that's a high compliment right anyways
guys so here's the deal each episode
will cover trending stories in TV then
we'll do a deep dive into one show that
we deem binge worthy today it's HS 1984
and then we're gonna leave you with our
fresh picks which are basically shows
that we think you should just add to
your watch list so let's jump right into
our stories you guys ready yeah let's do
it okay Netflix has officially confirmed
stranger thanks for so in a teaser
released online earlier this week we
learned pretty much nothing except for
the tease that says we're not in Hopkins
anymore but I don't know guys I think
the boys to live in Hawkins right so
we're still gonna see some Hawkins
you're definitely still gonna see some
Hawkins but as they set up the entirety
of season 3 they're gonna grow beyond it
and they kind of have to it was a nice
homegrown feel at the very beginning
they expanded on it in season 2 yeah and
then they crack the door open for more
locations in season 3 we're definitely
going beyond Hawkins yeah 100% and I'm
excited for that I think they're gonna
be time traveling is that a wild
speculation I don't then the entirety of
season 3 making references to Back to
the Future
I don't yeah like a DeLorean pops up
also the Harvard pops out they've
covered so much pop culture and are
trying to kind of reinvent these various
tropes I feel like time travels next on
their list yeah I think you might be
guessing for the wrong franchise I think
they're gonna talk to him I think
they're gonna time travel what Fast and
the Furious 9 that's right there another
series that I'm super stoked for and are
trending news story is Disney has
announced that Deborah Chow will be
taking the helm for the upcoming obi-wan
Kenobi series for Disney Plus so child
previously directed episodes of the
Mandalorian which is scheduled to debut
with the streaming series on November
11th I am NOT leaving my house when the
Mandalorian and all these Star Wars
series come out I've bought some adult
diapers I'm just gonna be sitting on my
couch for a weeks thanks all right I'm
never coming to your apartment that's
why I don't have friends it's just caked
and poo it's so gross I just like ones
Disney Plus comes out like do you guys
feel like you're ever gonna leave me
okay no I guess not no I mean I'm not
going to his capture I'll stay on my
couch I'm really excited for the
mandalorian though yeah I'm gonna stay
home sweet home gladly far away from you
guys yes I'm gonna be watching as much
Mandalorian as possible because this is
Star Wars we're talking about this is
gonna be high quality TV across the
board
Jon Favreau I trust and in the directors
he's already chosen for Mandalorian I
trust so if they looked at the work that
she did in that show and they want to
bring her on to something as epic is an
obi-wan kenobe series I mean how long
have we been asking for obi-wan Kenobi
to come back it's finally happening if
they pick her for the job I have all the
faith in the world and she's the TV
resume to prove it I know she's telling
I love what she did on the episodes of
mr. robot but our last story for the day
guys is we got a look at the new M night
Shyamalan series servant coming to Apple
TV Plus this fall and the teasers are
pretty weird and kind of creepy with did
you guys see that baby rocking back and
forth
that's something weird going on with and
that's not a real baby there's no way
that's a real I know that has to be some
type of CGI babe I hope it's not a real
baby it's a rubber feel so weird when
they show you their baby you're like oh
it's so cute that looks like no baby
I've ever laid on crickets fine a baby
that's a rubber baby that it got
animated with life somewhere along the
lines I am night great super creepy but
so excited for that because he's always
so secretive and I know he's gonna be at
New York Comic Con this week so I can't
wait to find out more about what I hear
yeah so guys before we deep dive into
American Horror Story 1984 I want to
take a quick break and talk about why
people are so obsessed with anthologies
and how they're oddly very similar to
pizza check it out okay so since we're
talking about one of my favorite
anthologies I start
to think about why we love Anthology so
much and I came to the conclusion that
it's because they're always mixing
things up with a new director a new
actor or a new storyline they're always
taking something that's really familiar
to us and keeping it fresh and I feel
like the same can be said when it comes
to picking a meal while you're chilling
at home watching your favorite shows
which is why I love for shut up pizza
with their premium toppings our
scratch-made sauce and 100% real cheese
they're taking something really familiar
and keeping it fresh so my point is just
like the shows you watch at home keep
your meals interesting - with four shut
up pizza okay guys so if your lights are
off it's probably a good time to turn
them on right now cuz we're gonna talk
about American Horror Story 1984 I'm
really trying to channel my inner Ryan
and Shane here I feel like that's
something you guys would say so the Ryan
Murphy created anthology series is back
for its ninth season this time taking
inspiration from the classic slasher
genre and in typical 8hs fashion we have
some returning faces in new places we
got Emma Roberts Billie lourd Leslie
Grossman and John Carroll Lynch my fave
returning to the franchise along with
some series newcomers we got Gus
Kenworthy and Glee alum Matthew Morrison
now at the time of this recording just
so you guys know we've only seen two
episodes so far but I feel like there's
so much to unpack already what are your
initial thoughts they really get right
into it
this season I mean ten minutes into the
first episode they're like hey let's go
to this crazy camp I know I'm going do
you guys want to come and they're like
yeah like nobody has to tell any friends
or family we're just like bye for the
summer yeah exactly so yes there's a lot
to unpack because we're really speeding
through the plot here and if they're
speeding through that early of a plot
point and they're going to if they're
getting to the camp that fast that means
that it's really gonna go off the rails
it must either what do you expect yeah I
think that's what we all hope right
Perry what do you think I've watched
enough scenes of American Horror Story
to know that whatever I think at this
point in time whatever my expectations
are gonna be completely wrong because if
I can come up with it right now Ryan
Murphy has something way more sneaky of
a sleeve right I feel like around
Episode five it's gonna go off the rails
but I personally love it I love the 80s
nostalgia I love Matt
Morrison's character all my friends that
are fans of Glee think it's somewhat
traumatizing to see him as this
character after yeah so funny but for me
the show is more fun and funny and not
scary like mr. jingles is a little bit
scary yeah exactly should be mr. jingles
the cat I I mean I kind of come to
expect this from the show I long for the
days of American Horror Story Murder
House when it was super scary and
unsettling and admittedly the show has
lost a lot of that along the way but the
fact that he's developed a show where he
can swing for the fences so wildly and
be able to do whatever he wants I kind
of applaud Ryan Murphy and the whole
team behind the show for that so the
fact that this is so colorful and crazy
and it's like a mash-up of a horror
comedy I kind of want to run with it I
mean the 80s my horror genre is pretty
silly in camping when you look back on
it I laughed really hard at all those
Jason movies when I was growing up maybe
I'm just a sadistic psychopath the first
Friday the 13th does have some I mean
there is a sort of an amateur look to it
that is really unsettling bannister
which they ape a few times in this first
pilot right out of the gate American
Horror Story 1984 with two episodes has
a 94% on the tomato meter closest after
that is asylum with an 84% and it was
the highest-rated season premiere since
freak show how does it compare it's so
hard to say because I've just invested
so much time of my life in American
heart it's like that's a big investment
that's like longer than the car -
thinking back to freakshow in particular
anybody who has watched the entirety of
that season knows you get invested for
90 percent of the show just for it not
to matter for the last 10 so I am always
just a little cautious when it comes to
jumping feet first into a season of
American Horror Story but if I just look
at these two episodes solid start I am
part but I agree with you it is an
emotional journey and it's a commitment
but I want to know from you guys do you
think that we're missing anything by not
having the American Horror Story staples
like Jessica Lange and Kathy Bates Sarah
Paulsen cuz you were talking about
message boards and I feel like when I
read the message boards a lot of people
are kind of bummed that
they're not in this season so do you
guys think we're losing anything do we
think they're gonna pop up in another
episode this season
my money's on Sarah Paulsen I think
during an interview she already admitted
she might pop up at a point and I mean I
think she's attached to this franchise
for as long as it lasts and when it
comes to like Kathy Bates and Angela
Bassett and Jessica Lange we're talking
about icons in the genre and in
filmmaking and TV shows across the board
whenever their absence is felt it's
gonna hurt a little yeah I I think they
will pop up maybe just even for a little
bit I would love for Kathy Bates to pop
up just because it kind of seems like
who wouldn't it seems like they're
they're setting up this like Freddy vs.
Jason scenario when it comes to mr.
jingles versus Richard Ramirez yeah I
you know weird like if I could just take
a villain from another movie I would
love for Kathy Bates from misery any
whelks and having a head to head the
head inside this camp and who really
cares about the campers just let those
three go at it
I think they'll pop up Sarah Paulson I
think will pop up yeah I wonder if part
of it though is obviously Ryan Murphy
loves making this show maybe wants to
continue to do it for several more years
like letting some of the other cast
members kind of have their day in the
Sun yeah cuz like Billie lourd is really
she's so she's so good yeah I think Emma
Roberts has so much scream queen cred I
mean she's Sidney Prescott's cousin she
was a killer and screamed for like I
think she could literally just take this
and we I personally feel like we're not
gonna see any of the staples in this
season her performance in scream 4 it
just shows the immense range that she
has and it's actually something you can
see an American Horror Story because
we've seen her play you know the
straight woman so to speak but also like
a crazy character who's super
over-the-top and sometimes you know
conniving and mean yeah I feel like
we're used to seeing her being conniving
and mean and I actually like her
character in 1984 I like that she's
playing kind of like the opposite of
what we're used to seeing her play you
think for now I was about to turn it on
its head it was kind of a harbinger of
doom in this series everywhere she goes
people the body count Rises well it's
like that one
that Billie lourd says to her where it's
something to the effect of it like if
all you see is the bad all you're gonna
because all you see the shadows is she
like she basically embodies that to be
fair she did see her future husband get
his head blown off oh I forgot about we
don't even necessarily know if any of
that is 100% sure if that is true I do
think she really went through all of
that but you never know I love that
scene that was a lot Ryan Murphy red
wedding was certainly effective okay
well one thing we do know for me I'm not
getting married
so one thing we do know is obviously
that the 80s are heavily influencing the
show right we talked about Friday the
13th we're also getting Michael Myers
Eve eyes but also there's true crime
from LA in this I want to know from you
guys do you think we're gonna see any
more real-life serial killers in the
show I will say I hope not and this may
be not to sound like like a wet blanket
here but I just I don't like when people
take real-life serial killers and be
like they're part of the MCU now join
the adventure
Oh is the Zodiac gonna come in here too
and like their real life like their
characters when they're like awful
people Ramirez is a monster monster 1984
but yeah I thought that too because
Xavier the character in 1984 mentions
Son of Sam yeah that's true yeah and I'm
like I just watched mine hunter you know
he was great in that they get money or
royalties I'm sure they couldn't no
they're not like Richard Ramirez is dead
right as far as we know yes I mean he's
a ghost died in 2013 okay okay well
that's good for us it's good for
everyone in a world where maybe there
would be other real-life serial killers
do you guys have one that you maybe
shame I mean you're gonna see ideally
you would want someone who you don't
want like glorify them and if you can
take a little liberties with them then
obviously zodiac cuz Brian Murphy can be
like well you know dream up some little
story about zodiac cuz nobody knows who
he is sure bring him into the picture
it's true right are there other shows
out there that you think our friends at
home should watch if they're loving 1984
right now I mean all I can think of is
the terror in the sense that each season
is kind of its own story it's not quite
as fun and light-hearted but it's it's a
different take each season on sort of a
thematic aliy similar horror story
rooted in history it's kind of hard to
think of a high quality serial a
serialized piece of content that is as
campy as this in the hole right yes
maybe dark dark is also set in the 80s
kind of for the majority of the first
season it's a German horror show but I
enjoy that I think it's very fun good
German stranger things it's like a
German it's only less stranger things in
the sense that a kid goes missing and
that's about it
but there's like an element of like a
town ecosystem kind of overarching
mystery santa clarita diet that show is
hands-down one of the best things
Netflix has ever made drew Barrymore and
Tim all of fun that's like a perfect
blend of horror comedy and just the
extremes they go to with the gore but
how charming that family is you like I
don't know that's just like the perfect
marrying of blood and gore but also
really charming content I agree I have
to check that out I love that one also
have you guys sort of two-sentence
horror stories on Netflix no no I've
heard they aired on the CW in August and
now it's on Netflix but it's also horror
anthology 30-minute episodes I love it
it's on my list
yeah and because they really take
everything we love about horror but put
a modern twist on it you guys would love
it it's so funny all right guys let's
talk theories now finally what do we
think the last camper is gonna be what
do we think is gonna happen
Perry like you have a lot of theories I
have I have so many theories and with
every single theory that I like I can
always find one or two points that make
it not possible but the main thing that
I latched on to right from the start was
the idea that it is basically a movie
being made within the series I mean just
look at the opening credits it all takes
place kind of on a TV screen and even at
the end of those credits when the tapes
are being shown and one kind of
out of it I don't know so many things
point at that and then the very first
time the hiker says to someone you're
not supposed to be here it made me think
that you know someone popped up in a
scene when they weren't yeah he says I'm
not supposed to die here yeah Ramirez
and I was like is this a game like maybe
Richard Ramirez walks into the filming
of a horror movie and he's caught off
guard that's interesting because when he
said I'm not supposed to be here I just
figured it was a ghost going through a
residual haunting like living the same
day over and over and well to be fair
the hiker is one of the things that does
not entirely work in the TV idea because
I do think the hiker is a ghost and
that's where I get to the Hellmouth
eerie so they exist hotel Cortez and
maybe here too where when people die in
a particular location they're dead but
they're never gone so if the hiker is
stuck there and who knows maybe Lesley
Grossman is stuck there and maybe she
really died at the very beginning and
she's another individual like him and
she's been stuck there Shane what are
your theories that movie theory is
really good I do think that Emma is
going to be the villain at the end of
the end of the show but then isn't that
so obvious I feel like Ryan wouldn't do
that
it could be the double block show horror
movie trope and he always turns them on
their heads as a woman I'm curious to
see if she is gonna be like the final
girl or not yeah I mean I think it's
also it's easy to see us an area where
she could be the final girl but I didn't
really think about that I did take her
on our word that the wedding happened
the way it did and that I guess
everything that's happened she's been
the only one that's been present so she
could just be lying I don't know maybe
it is easy to think that she could be
the real villain of the of the series
but maybe that's not as big and crazy of
a theory but I do think that's where
it's gonna end I think chef birdy she's
sketchy to me she worries she why was it
she they planted this seed
I don't know how deliberate is if it's
just a red herring but is it Xavier at
the very beginning said he was cast in a
role as a killer
and then he very deliberately says that
he's a man
that actor and went and studied Stella
Adler and then the guy he knows does get
the steak through the back of his head
and he invites everyone to the camp
right so this is his way of kind of
method acting might be time travel so
you're just reminding me of something
else there's a time-travel idea too
because at the beginning
xaviar says he rear-ended Billy and
Lauren's character and that's what
happens at the end of apocalypse so
there's another theory going around out
there that maybe they have time traveled
in order to stop stop the creation of
Mallory Billy Lords character in
Apocalypse because Cody fern in
Apocalypse is told that in order to you
know enact his plan there can't be any
witches so he'd have to go back in time
I don't know that is a theory you need
to write that down and take credit for
that thank God were recording this
there's that happens I will die to be
fair there's a lot of reports out there
a lot of people on YouTube and on
message boards theorizing about all this
stuff so I can't claim credit to all of
it as imagine as Murphy our link seasons
like that yeah yeah a lot of lot of them
so my theory is that the aliens from
asylum it's the 80s right there's got to
be a lian's guys I mean et aliens
predator like there's got to be a lian's
in this season they're gonna come and
they have the power to resurrect people
so I think they resurrected the camp
counselor from 1970 and the aliens are
gonna come and just destroy all and
maybe we'll see the witches again
because I think I remember seeing an
interview where the witches would be
back and he's doing ten seasons so I
want season ten to be witches verse
aliens I mean the fact is anything yeah
the fact that all of this is on the
table is a true testament to how fun the
show the fact that we're like could the
aliens could be time travel could be you
know agreed time will tell also I want
Margaret and night strangler to hook up
because I feel like there was also some
some sexual tension there on the table
this is like the end of cabin in the
woods
theories are so good we could go on and
on obviously but before we wrap up guys
I need to ask you who do you think this
show is far and are you gonna stick with
it well I think you already know I'm
gonna stick with it but for anybody who
likes American Horror Story out there
the seasons
so this is for an American Horror Story
fan if you want to keep up with its
must-watch I also think if you're just a
fan of 80s horror and yeah if you're a
fan ease horror you should stick with
the show ha I'm certainly gonna stick
with it I love it
I'm sticking with it I think it's good
for AHS fans but also if you're not a
fan I think it's accessible enough that
if this is the tip of the iceberg and
there's gonna be some crazy twist that
connects to other seasons it's a great
jumping-off point I agree with you guys
I think this is a season where new
people can kind of hop on and join the
bandwagon okay so before we go I want
you guys to tell me what your fresh
picks are so these are shows that you
think everyone should just watch doesn't
have to do with horror shows that people
should add to their watch list
what are you guys watching I'm sticking
in the horror genre and I'm going to
highly recommend Channel Zero on shudder
right now you can actually stream all
four seasons it's another anthology
series and they're all based on
creepypasta stories killers highly
highly inventive very well done yet
another show actually now I'm three for
three with this type of thing where you
get one season of a show they set the
bar they're never fall below it every
season of that show is phenomenal Wow
Wow also sold me on that very a tooth
man tooth man if you don't like people
covered in teeth don't watch it I'm not
going to stick in the horror genre I'm
gonna talk about Tara's house that is
not scary at all it is not scary at all
it's actually the most hypnotic and a
beautiful and delightful one of the most
beautiful and delightful shows I've ever
watched
it's a Japanese reality show it's a
Japanese reality show where they take I
think six or seven strangers put them in
a house and they're all just wonderful
to each other it's not pre-produced
there's no drama one of the big arcs of
the season is who ate another person's
steak in the house this is so it's
there's a piece of steak in the fridge
and someone stole and that's like the
big point of drama is like one of the
big arcs of the season and then every
now and then they'll cut back to a panel
of comedians that will comment they're
basically like a proxy for the audience
it's just a just a delight it is like a
ASMR it is just soothing it's hypnotic
like a great British baking show as if
not yeah yes I've been obsessed with the
Dark Crystal Age of resistance it's a
prequel to the movie which I kind of
like but the
Aries is sweeping it's like a Lord of
the Rings style epic there's a lot of
puppets the cast is crazy
I rarely binge shows nowadays but this
is one that I watched in two or three
days so Dark Crystal it's amazing I
can't talk it up enough what about you
Nance what are you watching I'm watching
the politician actually finished it Ryan
Murphy's other show that aired last week
on Netflix and I feel like the void of
Jessica Lange in 1984 is really filled
for me in the politician but it's about
this overachiever perfectionist kid
that's running for student body
president in hopes that it'll help him
become president of the United States
one day and I'm like a perfectionist so
I totally relate and there's already a
cliffhanger for season 2 so I think you
guys should watch it anyways guys that's
our show thank you so much
Perry Ryan Shane hey what my so quit I
love you guys thanks for joining me and
if you guys want more on American Horror
Story 1984 head on over to Ron Tomatoes
calm also comment below tell us all your
theories I want to read all your
comments how you think this is gonna end
remember we're all in this together also
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell so you
don't miss any future episodes it's free
and next episode we're talking Batwoman
I'm not surprised and I'll see you guys
next time hey
[Music]